Continuing in Al Wajeez fi Fiqh
as-Sunnah wal Kitab al-Aziz
in the chapter regarding an-najasat, the
various types of filth
that person is obligated
to
purify himself.
And when we say purify, we're speaking
about the clothing, the body, and the
place of salah in order to pray. In
order for a person's prayer to be
considered valid.
And
we have gone over
eight specific
types of najasa
that were listed by the author.
And
these types of najasa
are
the
types which have a clear authentic
evidence to support from the Quran and
from the Sunnah.
Now, whatever is not on this list
may be considered unclean.
May be considered inappropriate for a
person to have on his clothing.
However,
it is not necessarily something that
will invalidate a person's prayer.
So, for instance,
to give an example of this,
one of the
points
that
one of the types of najasa
that the author mentions is a rowa thul
[Arabic recitation]
The
waste of an animal which is
impermissible to eat.
And those words are refined and chosen
very carefully.
Which means that
what we understand from this
is that an animal which is permissible
to eat
its waste is not considered a type of
najasa.
Let's take a chicken for instance.
A chicken's
waste or a chicken's urine.
It is not a type of najasa.
Meaning that if it were on a person's
clothing or in a place of prayer or on a
person's body, it would not invalidate
or compromise a person's prayer.
However,
does that necessarily mean that it is
clean?
No.
Does that necessarily mean that it is
appropriate for a person to pray
with the ability to clean these things
and to pray with this on his person or
on his clothing? Is it even appropriate
for a person to keep this on his
clothing unless they are in the middle
of doing something, you know, cleaning
or working on a farm or what have you?
The answer is what? No, of course not.
This is not clean and it's not
considered appropriate.
But it is not a type of najasa. Najasa
means that it compromises the validity
of a person's prayer.
It compromises the validity of a
person's salah.
Just because it's not on this list
doesn't necessarily mean that it is
clean. Doesn't necessarily It's not just
black and white.
However, we have to be able to quantify
the things that will compromise a
person's prayer.
And so, this list
is what the scholars of fiqh have
debated and pined over and gathered,
sifting through the verses of the Quran,
the narrations of the Prophet Sallallahu
alayhi wa sallam, to bring a coherent
list for us to be able to memorize and
then we are able to We are now equipped
to worship Allah Subhana wa Ta'ala. We
understand what's expected of us. We
understand what is what is not
tolerated.
So,
how many things, let's do a little bit
of a review, how many types of najasa
did we mention?
Huh?
Eight. Very good.
The first and second
human feces and urine. So, human waste.
Okay, three and four
al-madhyu wal-wadyu.
Al-madhyu is pre-ejaculate
and al-wadyu is a kind of pus that comes
out of the bladder after urinating.
Tayyib, number five
[Arabic recitation]
The waste of animals which are
impermissible to eat. And of course,
with that goes the rest of the animal
which is, you know,
it's liquid, it's it's blood, it's pus,
it's saliva, etc. Okay.
Number six
So, menstrual blood and postpartum
blood. And remember, we are taking these
words very, very
deliberately, which means
that whatever is not on this list
is a list as well.
Right?
So, we have a list of that which will
compromise a person's prayer. But this
list also makes another list for us in
our minds. And that which is implied by
this list, what is considered to be
maybe unclean but is not a najasa, what
people confuse as a type of najasa, etc.
Right?
and so, we understand from this
menstrual blood or postpartum blood,
that means that blood from any other
part of the body
is not considered to be a type of
najasa, right?
A person has a cut, they have some blood
on their clothing, this will not
compromise a person's prayer in the
correct opinion. Okay?
Number Number seven,
the dog The saliva of a dog.
The saliva of a dog, and with that goes
the rest of the dog, right? And is there
another animal with that?
The swine,
right?
The pig. And we mentioned the evidences
for that that Ash-Shafi'i rahimahullah
mentioned and
a very large majority of the
scholars. And the last and final type of
najasa,
al-maytah.
The dead animal. So, this now is any
animal which is otherwise permissible to
eat, but it died without being properly
slaughtered. Correct?
And so,
this list is very important for you to
memorize it, pine it, pine over it,
contemplate it. Remember, when you have
a book this that is a book of fiqh
that has been refined over years and
years of scholars
debating it and debating the
evidences and so forth, the evidences
become more refined.
And so, the list becomes more refined.
The words are very deliberate. They're
chosen very, very deliberately, which
means that we can extract a lot of
knowledge from a list this, right?
And so,
al-maytah, which is any animal that is
permissible to eat otherwise, but has
not been
slaughtered properly or slaughtered
by the right person or slaughtered for
the incorrect reason, cuz there's three
elements that goes into slaughtering,
right?
The way the slaughtering takes place,
the purpose of the slaughtering, and the
person who is slaughtering.
All right? So, when it comes to the
person who is slaughtering, that person
must be one of three types of people,
right? Must be a
Muslim or Christian or Jew, right? And
the way of slaughtering,
which means that
how must a person slaughter?
As the prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam said in Sahih al-Bukhari, "Ma
[Arabic recitation]
He said, "Whatever has had the blood
expelled from it upon slaughtering, and
Allah's name was mentioned upon
slaughtering, then it is permissible to
eat." And then we have the intention of
the slaughtering. And that intention is
what?
That it that it must be for Allah,
or if it is just a regular slaughtering,
person is slaughtering for meat, they're
hunting, they want to eat, it's not
slaughtered for other than Allah. That's
the important part. When we say
slaughtered for other than Allah,
meaning
slaughtered in a form of worship of
other than Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala,
right? So, if I take
an animal, and I slaughter it with the
intention of exalting another person or
another thing as I exalt Allah, this now
is a major type of shirk.
And this now is a type of maytah, right?
But if I were to not be slaughtering for
worship, I'm slaughtering out of custom,
I'm slaughtering because I'm hunting, or
I'm slaughtering because we need some we
need some meat in the house or what have
you. This isn't a form of worship, is
it? So, what's important is that it is
not slaughtered for other than Allah.
These are three conditions for meat to
be made permissible. Now, there are
three exceptions
to this
meat. What are those exceptions?
Any
aquatic animal.
Any aquatic animal, meaning an animal
that lives
in the water.
What about amphibians?
Amphibians
live in the water and on land.
Are they permissible to eat or not?
The answer is yes, in the correct
opinion, they are permissible to eat.
Even if they spend most of their time on
land, it is still permissible to eat.
It's considered part of the ocean in the
correct opinion.
And the second type
is the locust.
Right? And the prophet
also
gave us two types of blood which are
permissible.
Right?
To eat.
Which is
which is what in English?
The spleen and the liver. These are
These retain a huge amount of blood.
Right? And if if if we were to
If if Allah
were to obligate us
to purify these organs from the blood
that they carry in order to eat them, it
would be a huge burden. Be almost
impossible. They're almost entirely
comprised of blood.
Okay? And
the second type of meta
insects. Very good. Masha Allah. Insects
mad dam alahu saye.
More specifically, that which does not
have flowing blood through veins, such
as insects, right?
bugs, insects, etc. And the third,
which is not a type of najasa, the third
exemption,
Mhm.
More more general than that.
Is any part of the animal
which blood does not flow through.
Okay? So, we've got bones, doesn't have
veins.
We've got teeth.
We've got claws, horns, tusks,
right?
claws,
nails, hooves,
hair.
These parts of any animal, even if it's
from a pig,
blood does not flow through it.
Therefore, it does not have the ruling
of being najis in itself.
Right? And the companions
when they would travel into the Roman
and Persian places, these things were
used, ivory was used, and
boar brushes to brush your hair, and
bone, and so forth. They never were
narrated to have rejected the use of any
of these things.
Nasal Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala bi manni
wa karami wa juddihi. And tomorrow
inshallah, we will begin speaking about
the way to purify each of these types of
najasa.
So, lock these types of
najasa in your mind. The only way that
you're going to retain this information
is if you review it in your mind.
Review it every day. Go through the list
once or twice a day. After a week or
two, it will be set and that's it.
You'll have it for the rest of your
life. Now, you can sit your children
down. You can teach them. You can set
anyone down. Teach them. You have an
entire list now of what is considered
najis and what is considered to be
not part of this list now.
[Arabic recitation]
nabiyina Muhammad. Nas'alullah ta'ala an